bonjour à tous et bienvenue c'est un
début de tour à destination annonçant un
peu mouvementée on devait suivre la
conférence de presse de fabien galthié
ce matin mais il a été testé positif au
co vide la conférence de presse a été
annulée ou on va quand même parler je
suis avec arnaud coudry du service des
sports du figaro salgado salut à tous du
coup on va discuter un peu de 2,7 compos
et aussi du statut des bleus finalement
pour ce pour ce tournoi arnaud on va
montrer la compo là qui vient d'être
annoncé est ce que cette compo elle est
surprenante ou pas non non on est
vraiment dans la continuité de 2 du
quinze de france qui a battu les all
blacks en novembre il ya juste deux
changements c'est le retour de julien
marchand au poste de talonneur qui était
le talonneur numéro un et qui était pas
là en novembre et l'autre changement qu
un peu la surprise du chef c'est dylan
scrutin en troisième ligne aile et donc
ça fait qu'on a faim il ya une option
qui est prise clairement de d'aligner
deux joueurs très aérien très bons en
touche donc on a dit l'entretien etc à
mandroux qui en qui est placée encore en
deuxième ligne à la basse et un
troisième ligne mais là il remonte d'un
cran et c'est pour avoir plusieurs
options à la fois dans le jeu courant
c'est des dégâts qui court beaucoup qui
sont très mobiles et qui sont très bons
en touche
choix tactique face à l'italie et ça
changera sûrement face aux autres
exactement ça peut évoluer tout à fait
il ya plein d'autres solutions on a
parlé en début de semaine peut-être d'un
retour de bernard le roux en deuxième
ligne c'est pas le cas il ya françois
cros aussi qui est une solution en
troisième ligne il ya vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup d'options surtout en troisième
ligne 3e insee très riches moments comme
ça il ya un absent alors pas forcément
sur le sur le quinze de départ c'est
jalibert n'est que les autres il a été
touché à la cuisse en coupe d'europe
avec bordeaux-bègles et a priori n'est
pas suffisamment remis pour pouvoir
jouer ce premier match du tournoi mais
après où il va revenir rapidement
alors vous n'hésitez pas pendant tout ce
live à poser vos questions on essaiera
d'y répondre au mieux possible je sais
me beaudry qui nous dit qu'il nous a
rejoints sur le live vous êtes déjà
nombreux à nous suivre est ce que on
peut dire que le quinze de france est
favori pour cette édition
ça s'est un peu enfin pour les autres
nations les autres nations du tournoi la
france est clairement favorite donc
c'est peut-être un moyen aussi de or
ajoute de la pression mais disons que
cette fameuse victoire contre les all
blacks en novembre a vraiment marqué les
esprits la france a signé son plus gros
succès de l'histoire contre les all
blacks hees a envoyé un message très
fort aux autres nations la france était
un peu en train de monter en puissance
avec une nouvelle génération les entames
à clé jalibert les jalibert les dupondt
tout ça et là ils ont clairement ont
frappé un grand coup à un an de la coupe
du monde est pour beaucoup la france est
favorite et je pense que la france enfin
l'équipe de france elle même a besoin de
gagner enfin un titre depuis la prise de
fonction de fabien galthié ils ont fait
deux fois deuxième lors des dernières
éditions la fois absolument qui gagne un
titre on se rappelle qu'en en comment
dire le dernier grand chelem de l'équipe
de france était en 2010 et en 2011
l'année d'après ils vont en finale de la
coupe du monde où il perd à trotter le
black donc c'est un marqueur très
important dans la progression d'une
équipe que de gagner un titre il est
justement très longtemps plus que le que
les que le que le quinze de france ne
s'est pas posé sur trois des six nations
alors que c'est une équipe majeure on a
eu encore on a connu bien sûr un énorme
passage à vide et depuis on remonte
petit à petit la porte ouais c'est ça
depuis l'arrivée de fabien galthié même
déjà pendant la dernière coupe du monde
où c'était jacques brunel qui était à la
tête de l'équipe 2 france et fabien
galthié étaient déjà arrivés dans le
staff donc il était déjà un petit peu
aux commandes semble sans le dire la
france avait montré un visage bien plus
séduisant que les dernières années où ça
a été vraiment d année noire pour le
quinze de france déroute historique en
quart de finale contre les all blacks en
2015 enfin ça a été vraiment très très
dur pour pour toute une génération de
joueurs qui a vraiment eu du mal pendant
vraiment de longues années quoi si c'est
une édition cette année deux des
destinations qui est très ouverte ah oui
on l'a vu parce qu'on dit oui la france
a battu les all blacks en novembre mais
l'irlande a battu les all blacks aussi
ils ont battu les sud africains
champions du monde donc le niveau
certains disent que le niveau maintenant
dans l'hémisphère nord est supérieur à
celui dans l'hémisphère sud on sas est
constatée en novembre les équipes du sud
sont un peu en fin de saison à sont
peut-être un peu fatigué mais en tout
cas le niveau est très très dense dans
l'hémisphère nord depuis depuis quelques
depuis la dernière coupe du monde en
fait le nîmois vraiment vraiment
augmenter quoi on va parler un peu des
différents équipe contre qui l'équipe de
france va jouer il y aura déjà
l'angleterre le l'angleterre qui chaque
année parce quand même pour le favoris
habituels est ce que cette année ils
peuvent s'attendre à gagner là c'est un
peu compliqué ils ont beaucoup d'absents
les anglais la ddjs le sélectionneur du
quinze de la rose doit faire face à une
cascade de blessures impressionnant
simon cohen farrell l'ouvreur et
capitaine
courtney lawes il manque le troisième
ligne sam and dry la faille a beaucoup
beaucoup de très bons joueurs anglais
qui sont absents et donc il ya de facto
un renouvellement ils font appel à des
jeunes
donc on va voir ce que ça donne le match
contre l'angleterre ce sera le dernier
du tournoi pour le quinze de france donc
si les deux équipes venaient à être
invaincue ça pourrait être la finale la
finale du tournoi lors de la dernière
journée c'est ça et en plus on se
rappelle quand même que c'est le cette
année années paires comme on en parlait
avant le live c'est ça on joue
l'angleterre et l'irlande à domicile ce
qui est toujours une bonne chose ouais
c'est ça les a des perses et les années
plus facile entre guillemets pour faire
le grand chelem effectivement parce
qu'on reçoit deux gros morceaux que sont
l'angleterre et l'irlande généralement
on dit que c'est bas 2010 était une
année paire
on a fait grand chelem c'était battant
les anglais lors de la dernière journée
à ce moment là effectivement
l'angleterre donc il ya le pays de
galles aussi pays de galles qui reste
qui est qui qui est tenant du titre et
qui peut tenter de faire le doublé ouais
c'est une équipe on en parle moins ça
peut être un peu moins clinquant mais
c'est très très très solide et surtout
c'est très très expérimenté c'est une
équipe qui a un vécu commun qui est
énorme et qui arrive à enchaîner les
succès et est toujours au très haut
niveau l'an dernier on les attendait pas
au final c'est eux qui remporte le
tournoi sans faire le grand chelem il
remporte quand même le tournoi c'est une
équipe on peut pas on ne peut absolument
pas les sous-estimer puis cette année
place de france va falloir aller à
cardiff au principality stadium
anciennement millénium où c'est très
très dur de s'imposer de rapporter
effectivement le pe le le pdl qu'il ya
toujours une ossature très très
expérimenté et qui il va avoir aussi
quelques absents
pas tant que ça enfin je pense pas que
là il est énormément d'absents mais le
l'ossature est très très importante sur
sur des joueurs comme ça je pense que
c'est franchement en terme d'expérience
il n'y a pas si l'angleterre à tous ses
cadres on peut parler que des équipes
aussi très expérimenté mais le pays de
galles ça reste ça reste redoutable il
ya aussi l'irlande l'irlande qui est qui
qui remporte souvent cette ordination
est-ce que là encore l'irlande est un
favori oui oui bien sûr voilà ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure l'irlande cet
automne ils ont battu les all blacks ils
ont battu les sud africains champions du
monde donc c'est vraiment une équipe
redoutable quoi c'est c'est pareil c'est
hyper solide ils sont vraiment pénibles
à jouer et c'est une équipe très très
forte en défense qu impose à un gros
pressing qui est toujours une grosse
densité physique ça reste une équipe
toujours très très compliquée à
manoeuvrer quoi on a dans les
commentaires 1 qui nous dit que dupont
comme meilleur joueur de
2,2 de tous les temps pour l'équipe de
france je sais pas pourquoi ils nous
disent ah
je sais pas si cela il doit parler on a
fait un classement cette semaine des on
avait fait monter un jury avec guy novès
je viens du puits un collègue ou de
fruits templiers de rmc un journaliste
du guardian pour essayer de déterminer
qui était le meilleur demi de mêlée de
l'histoire du quinze de france et c'est
antoine dupont qui arrivait en tête donc
ça fait jaser ça fait parler voilà
forcément mais rappelons que même pour
guy novès antoine du point est le
meilleur demi de mêlée de l'histoire du
quinze de france donc ça passe ça te
rappelle quand même que ce joueur qui
arrivait en france qui est qui est qui
et qui a une énorme star maintenant
entendu bon c'est vraiment devenu le lam
cette équipe ouais c'est ça c'est ça bat
déjà là en l'absence de charles hall
yvon qui est blessé il a été nommé
capitaine donc c'est pas rien et puis
c'est vraiment un joueur décisif comme
on en a rarement eu en équipe de france
et est rarement eu à ce poste de demi de
mêlée donc c'est vraiment une c'est un
peu oui effectivement l'âme de l'équipe
le leader de jeu le leader il aime à
rappeler qu'il est plus leader par
exemple par l'exemple que par la parole
ou tu dois pas tout en parler pour tout
et rien dire mais c'est un joueur qui
est qui est vraiment décisif comme on en
a rarement eu quoi est ce que c'est le
meilleur joueur du monde en ce moment ah
oui mais là ça peut la question la
question ne se pose pas il a été élu par
par la fédération internationale
meilleurs joueurs c'était arrivé que
deux fois avant faut le rappeler il y
avait juste eu fabien galthié qui avait
été élu meilleur joueur du monde en 2002
et thierry dusautoir qui avait été élu
meilleur joueur du monde en 2011 après
la finale perdue contre les all blacks
est là quand on parle aux autres aux
autres nations de antoine dupont ils
sont à face à la question se pose pas
selon moi c'est effectivement le
meilleur joueur du monde sans discussion
on parlait un peu des différences qui
font apparaître de l'irlande de
l'angleterre il ya les causes aussi les
causes qu'on ne parle pas trop qui nous
réussit pas du tout c'est ça on est sûr
on est sur trois défaites lors des
quatre derniers matches contre l'ecosse
quoi c'est pas l'équipe la wave dont on
parle le plus si on parle beaucoup les
flower of scotland des ihm tout ça de
l'ambiance du murrayfield meurent et
fils il va falloir y aller pour le
quinze de france est et gagner quoi ce
qui est absolument pas ce qui est
absolument pas facile du tout quoi c'est
quoi les dangers de cette équipe décosse
elle est assez on a longtemps reproché à
l'ecosse de pas être costaud devant ne
pas avoir des avants très fort très
puissant mais les choses se sont
vraiment améliorer ça c'est sûr dans ce
secteur mais c'est surtout une équipe
qui joue beaucoup qui qui envoient du
jeu un peu dans tous les sens qui arrive
à enflammer on pense à aa l'ouvreur
écossais fine russell qui joue au racing
92 qui est vraiment bon il peut avoir
des jours sans et un peu fantasque tout
ça est un peu inconstant mais il peut
déverrouiller un match et enflammer un
match comme comme peu de joueurs savent
le faire
et puis on à l'italie l'italie qui est
notre premier adversaire et l'italie en
tout cas eux ils vivent à on peut dire
après un calvaire depuis quelques années
dans leurs progrès c'est compliqué pour
l'italie ça fait des années que ça dure
ils n'ont pas gagné depuis 2015 et un
succès en écosse et ils restent sur 32
défaites consécutives dans le tournoi
donc
l'équipe qui perdra contre l'italie
je pense qu'il restera à peu dans les
airs mais sans celle qui s'est planté
mais là en plus on peut l'italie
étonnamment plus ils ont renouvelé
complètement leur leur équipe avec des
jeunes joueurs on pense à garder ici
entre l'ouvreur qui joue à montpellier
il ya des joueurs qui sortent des jeunes
des jeunes joueurs donc ça demande
sûrement un peu de temps pour qu'il se
fasse un peu la moelle qui se sentent
leurs six un peu mais ça reste
une équipe qui doit qui doit progresser
quoi et qui elle peut pas s'agrandir
c'est compliqué pour eux quoi après on
est toutes en train de remettre en
question leur place dans le tournoi des
six nations en disant il faudrait que
deux à l'équipe ou à la retour à cinq ou
même que une équipe comme la géorgie qui
est très bonne dans le tournoi b le
deuxième tournoi pour les nations un peu
mineur puisse avoir sa chance dans le
grand troyes joue tous les trois jours
quoi peut pas avoir deux matches dans
une semaine c'est forcément un match par
semaine et donc tous les week-ends son
prix on le voit avec le top 14 ça
s'arrête jamais top 14 coupe d'europe
tournoi des six nations on est même au
rugby à faire des doublons c'est à dire
qu'il ya des matches de championnat
pendant qu' à l'équipe de france qui
joue donc le calendrier vraiment
surchargé et l'a donc si on rajoute
l'équipe dans le tournoi ça rajoute
encore une date ça serait à mon avis
intenable juste le fait que d'aller en
géorgie ce n'est pas la même chose que
la leur d'italie oui c'est ça faire des
jeux pour ce que les droits télé surtout
sont pas les mêmes la géorgie peut pas
offrir des droits télé assez conséquent
contrairement à l'italie toi
effectivement il ya une question aussi
qui se pose et on l'a revu aujourd'hui
avec fabien galthié ses locaux vides le
coc vide qui peut une nouvelle fois
rabattre on va dire
les cartes est ce que au final la france
ce n'est quand même pas trop mal sortie
puisqu'elle a eu pas mal de jeu de deux
joueurs testés positifs il ya pas si
longtemps oui c'est ça on ségou le stade
toulousain et le club qui fournit le
plus d'internationaux et il ya eu un
mini cluster à toulouse ça fait qu'il ya
plein de joueurs qui ont été testés
positifs à sa base de la charnière du
point de tama qu'on a eus by marchand je
longe cros ils ont tous étaient positifs
donc c'était il ya deux semaines donc
maintenant ils reviennent de ça la
question maintenant c'est de savoir ce
qu'ils vont avoir
du rythme est-ce qu'ils vont pas manquer
de rythme plutôt on a vu que le dernier
match du stade toulousain contre contre
le racing 92 à ernest wallon à toulouse
les dupondt ntamack qui n'était pas
fringants fringant quoi ils n'avaient
pas le même le même peps et le même
éclat que d'habitude donc là on va voir
si le stade de france aura réussi à lire
met bien d'aplomb et bien en jambes quoi
mais c'était une des questions de
thibault giroud l'entraîneur de
l'entraîneur de la prépa physique quoi
du quinze de france a dit que entre
dupont manqué un peu de rythme parce
qu'il est donc là il a joué contre le
racing le auquel dernier sinon son
dernier match c'était mi décembre donc
il a passé un mois et demi sans jouer
quoi donc on va voir comment ses biens
entre entre nous que ce soit l'italie en
premier c'est ça parce que comme ça
l'italie nous permet de commencer un
match sur sur comment dire sur des bases
où on a moins d'adversité mais même si
le but de l'italie c'est quand même
aussi de marquer beaucoup de points
parce que pour moi ça peut jouer et ça
se joue maintenant à la différence de
points exactement exactement et ça a
joué des tours à la france lors des
dernières éditions où ils n'ont pas pris
des bonus contre l'italie ou des choses
comme ça et au final tous les points
comptent à part si on fait le grand
chelem mais s'il ya une et s'il ya
plusieurs équipes pour une défaite les
moindres points grappillés peut faire la
différence et la france l'a payé très
cher lors des dernières éditions donc là
c'est sûr contre l'italie les joueurs de
l'équipe de france répète tout le temps
où on respecte l'italie 1 1 c'est pas
les matches les uns après les autres
mais c'est presque ça et
et quand même ils sont un peu dans
l'obligation de gagner avec le bonus
contre l'italie pour parce que toutes
les autres équipes vont faire quoi bon
ce monde et que c'est au fond pas lâcher
des points à 7 ans dont la voix il sait
qu'il est joueur à suivre déjà du côté
français un peu quelques erreurs le
grand public va découvrir un peu lors de
ce tournoi balle à côté français en fait
il n'y a pas vraiment de découverte
puisque c'est on est sûr déjà le
les joueurs du mois de novembre on à
l'ossature grosso modo proche proche de
celle contre les all blacks je pense que
on va continuer à découvrir parce qu'on
les gens le grand public le voit
peut-être pas au quotidien avec mois
avec perpignan c'est l'arrière melvin
jaminet qui est un cas un peu des
difficultés avec perpignan qui lutte
pour se maintenir en top 14 mais qui est
toujours très bon quand ils arrivent en
équipe de france donc lui on va
continuer à le suivre et puis bah disons
que maintenant quand même quand on
regarde l'équipe de france ouverte au
moment où antoine dubuquoy et on attend
vos ses coups de génie
ces démarrages comment
ils ont remis les adversaires c'est ça
va être un peu ça suive pas il ya aussi
ce que vous demandez aussi beaucoup
c'est la complémentarité entre lui et
ntamack est ce que c'est encore une
question qui se pose ou plus ou non
franchement c'est la cce enfin ils sont
vraiment hyper hyper complémentaires et
hyper habitués à jouer ensemble se
connaissent maintenant depuis pas mal de
saisons
lors de la dernière coupe du monde déjà
il était associé donc c'est vraiment ils
sont vraiment non ils sont et c'est
vraiment une charnière que
la planète rugby nous envie vraiment
effectivement et en dehors de la france
et s'il ya d'autres joueurs un peu à
suivre que là pour le coup puisqu'elle
va découvrir ce qui est marrant c'est de
suivre en angleterre l'ouvreur qui
s'appelle marcus smith c'est un jeune de
22 ans qui joue à arles le queens et qui
est vraiment la nouvelle petite pépite
du rugby anglais et en plus il va être
il va forcément jouer puisque
l'emblématique owen farrell donc été
ouvreur et capitaine de l'angleterre est
blessé et sera absent toute la durée du
tournoi donc marcus pis marcus smith va
avoir l'occasion vraiment se mettre en
lumière et c'est un joueur super super
attrayant super spectaculaire on
pourrait dire qu'ils qui peuvent faire
la différence à tout moment quoi ça peut
être lui la révélation de ce tournoi
ouais c'est ça enfin disons qu'on va
apprendre à bien le connaître parce
qu'avant il était il était un peu dans
l'ombre des autres demi d'ouverture
anglais que ce soit ual farrell ou
george ford au tout ça et là à 22 ans
c'est l'âge de romain tamack ils ont le
même âge donc on lui aussi va avoir
l'occasion de s'exprimer lors dé leur
destination ce qui est important c'est
là c'est la constance est arrivé à être
fort tout le temps est ce que c'est
quelque chose que la france réussir à
faire et c'est un peu ce qui lui a fait
défaut cela étant bah ouais on l'a vu
l'an dernier où on perd contre l'ecosse
au dernier moment
dernière action perd contre l'ecosse
alors qu'on était on aurait pu prétendre
à la victoire finale sans grand chelem
mais non c'est vrai la constance c'est
ça sert aimerait arriver à répéter les
efforts et à être et enchaîner les
matchs à faire des bonnes performances
quoi qu'on arrive à faire un match
génial et puis un autre un peu plus
moyen
il faut arriver vraiment à la constance
la sur la durée et tenir la durée c'est
ce qui va être important quoi est ce que
justement on peut dire que le fait
d'avoir cette même ossature depuis un
moment il ya peu du coup permettre à
l'équipe de france d'être plus mieux
armé que l'an dernier par exemple ouais
c'est ça on voit quoi c'est ça c'est les
mêmes joueurs qui sont en place donc ils
prennent de l'expérience il s'endurcit
s'ils ont des automatismes tout ça le
fait qu'ils arrivent à enchaîner parce
qu'on a longtemps au chai au quinze de
france 2 que ce soit la valse permanente
des joueurs importants quelle mauvaise
performance le joueur saute et le demi
d'ouverture il changeait tout le temps
la charnière c'est pareil alors que là
maintenant que les joueurs sont
installés ils ont leur chance et le
staff leur fait confiance et leur laisse
leur laisse le temps de s'exprimer sur
la durée donc là maintenant c'est sûr
qu'on attend confirmation et et qui
gagne des titres très bien des coûts de
merci beaucoup arnaud d'avoir été
d'avoir été ici pour nous parler du
tournoi des six nations du début du
tournoi qui commence donc du coup ce
dimanche contre l'italie premier petit
est comme on veut comme on l'a dit on
espère le remporter parce que derrière
il y aura comme on l'a dit des grosses
équipes à battre merci beaucoup à
raphaël à la régie merci à vous d'avoir
été très nombreux à nous suivre et à
commenter ceux qui nous suivent sur
youtube n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
pour suivre nos prochains live et moi je
vous dis à bientôt pour de nouveaux
directs sur figaro live